a principio de esta semana Abogados del
presidente Joe biden descubrieron cerca
de diez documentos confidenciales en el
centro de diplomacia y compromiso Global
en un instituto en el centro de
Washington que yo vayan creo después de
haber sido vicepresidente Pues en las
últimas horas los abogados de la
presidente biden encontraron más
información confidencial en otro lugar
así lo revelaron Fuentes que prefirieron
guardar su anonimato estos
descubrimientos se conocen semanas
después de que Maryland el fiscal
general estadounidense nombrara a
Jacques consejero especial para llevar a
cabo una investigación sobre el mal
manejo de cientos de documentos
clasificados que fueron llevados a mar
al lago después de que Trump terminó su
presidencia en este caso para revisar el
descubrimiento de documentos
clasificados de biden recurrió al fiscal
Federal John launch de Chicago un
remanente de la administración de Donald
Trump cabe mencionar también que los
abogados de Joe biden le notificaron a
las agencias de gobierno y ya el
departamento de Justicia abrió una
investigación para conocer las causas de
estos hechos